mira lo realmente entró en erupción dios
mío los habitantes de la isla caribeña
de san vicente que no siguieron las
indicaciones iniciales de evacuar
acabaron huyendo de la erupción
despavoridos
estamos ya nos estamos llenos no puedo
más tengo que moverme tengo que correr
las imágenes apenas se alcanzan a captar
la enorme columna de ceniza
el volcán llamado sufría entró en
erupción el viernes por primera vez en
40 años ahora gran parte de san vicente
está cubierta por el polvo y el aire o
el azufre estas personas fueron
evacuadas en barco a otras islas
cercanas mientras que otras miles se
refugiaron en albergues proporcionados
por el gobierno un coordinador local
intenta tranquilizar a la gente todo va
según lo planeado esto es lo que el
gobierno ha estado poniendo en práctica
no es un simulacro en total más de
15.000 residentes han tenido que oír los
científicos dicen que la sofiex podría
seguir expulsando sustancias durante
varios días más o incluso semanas